le brise-glace canadien ces trois
poursuit son périple qu'il mène de
toronto à victoria en empruntant le
grand passage du nord ouest
notre journaliste marie laure josselin
et à bord depuis la fin du mois de
juillet elle nous livre son contrat j'ai
des derniers jours marie-laure dont vous
avez monté à bord du c3 avec ayew et du
nunavut où est ce que vous êtes les
enfants et on a quitté key qui tarde
joie qui a foiré comme vous le voyez on
est enfin naviguer dans des glaces on
longe la côte pour que ce soit plus
facile je vous laisse apprécier le
spectacle très beau et sa direction de
clyde river d'accord et comment gérer
l'exposition jusqu'à maintenant savent
pas plutôt bien on dit qu'il a la
flexibilité la clé en en arctique et que
le chemin le plus court n'est jamais le
meilleur on a du sens un détour de deux
jours en plein air où ç'a brassé
beaucoup et tout le mois et une malade
sur le bateau faut le reconnaître mais
c'est le seul moyen parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de glace en ce moment à cause
du réchauffement climatique et beaucoup
de glace qui sont descendus ou aux
foules l'on ferait du sens en grande
forme et le hier les participants de
l'étape cette quantité est dorée nouveau
parti ce sont des affiches sont arrivés
dont la rameuse mylène paquette mais au
final on ne fait pas toujours le
programme prévu mais on ne fait pas une
bonne sur ce voile est éteint après un
nouveau nom je ne connais pas ma
géographie du canada parfaitement ce que
vous avez sur base essentielle qui
s'appelle pas de l'open au nunavut
cet endroit c'est particulier millions
oui mais c'est unique en fait
intéressant de l'histoire est
intéressante de fabio tina et ongles
parce que pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale les américains avaient repéré
fertile pour faire un terrain
d'atterrissage pour les avions pour
pouvoir surveiller en fait ce qu'ils
pouvaient venir par le nord d'une menace
n'importe quoi et puis après pendant la
guerre froide ils ont construit les
stations météo il y en a eu plusieurs en
plusieurs dizaines le long de l'article
après vingt ans qu'ils ont quitté les
canadiens aux et offrit à pablo thing
island effet les américains mais quand
ils font partie ils ont tout laissé là
donc quand on dit tous les essais sont
les bâtiments les déchets des 18
montagnes des villes talent dont ces
sols contaminés au vtt par exemple
depuis 2012 gouvernement canadien à mila
a donné un contrat une entreprise pour
nettoyer ça coûte beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent pour nettoyer cette
île est donc le nettoyage est en cours à
claudine island on n'a pas pu
s'approcher france on peut même pas deux
manières y aller mais il ya certaines
sommes partis de licence qui est pas
très intéressantes qui permettent de
découvrir qui ont permis en tout cas des
chercheurs dont une chercheuse de l'uqam
de découvrir dans les fûts anciens
morceaux de la terre en fait comment ils
ont fait ça elle cherche surtout dans le
monde et des roches anciennes mais à
pablo ping à la primerose plus jeune et
elle a découvert à l'intérieur de ses
proches et bien c'est cette saison ce
morceau de terre du noyau terrestre
stylisme et iquique femme à coups qui
nous mélanger toutes à peu près tous les
ingrédients et puis vous savez pas
pourquoi il ya un morceau de faire du
noir tout ce qui ne s'est pas mélanger
oui eh bien c'est comme ça qu'on a
prouvé ses morceaux très ancien moine a
donc de pouvoir faire des analyses tous
au cours des prochains mois pour sept
chercheurs mais il ya cette station
météo a pas loupé mais y en a bien
d'autres également là qui ont été
construites après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
quatre ont fait la station météo
c'est un le gouvernement a appris à
donner des contrats en tout cas pour pas
de l'obtenir il en est un autre endroit
en 2012 pour nettoyer des contaminés
tout ce qui a donc on va venir enlever
les huiles ce talent ça veut dire
retirer les bâtiments qui sont restés à
l'abandon vraiment les habitants ont
quitté l'île en il y avait des gens qui
habitaient à pablo pino et l'emmener
dans les années 60 ils ont quitté parce
qu'ils avaient pu service qui avait plus
rien de tout et tout le monde était
parti
ils ont été relocalisés notamment acquis
par genci les théières et apprendre une
langue où on s'en va et donc le
nettoyage complet de la terre et aussi
de sia en force sur terre donc il n'est
pas question de l'utiliser à nouveau ces
lieux comme station météo s'est fermé
complètement non voilà c'est en mai
qu'on s'est abandonné abandonné voilà
donc les prochaines étapes de votre père
et fais ce que vous avez des objectifs
particuliers pour sakineh des recherches
en tant que celles pour les recherches
sont en pole pour le bateau elle tomba
ici je vous montre où elle est un
laboratoire très sophistiquée et à
l'intérieur donc on a nos certificats
d'or est à 23 projets qui sont montés et
les scientifiques sont par exemple des
tests sous marin ace et de palme un
endroit assez préservé le transforme
maritimes sont en fait de plus en plus
fréquent des attentes savoir se fait pas
par le territoire du nord ouest est
ouvert qu'on fasse pas ce moment et donc
ils prennent des textes de son marasme
il faut aussi de la révolte de plastique
de micro plastiques
quand on atterrit enfin quand on avait
quand on va sur la terre on y récolte du
plan sont des acariens qui va exciter
23e recherche s'ils sont extras comme
cantons de l'est comme les smartphones
et pour pouvoir justement avoir fait un
tour globale par le nord de retrouver
d'autres recherches autant de de la
veine du phytoplancton des micro
plastiques du son aussi prochaine de sa
vie vont essayer de trouver des six lits
vous savez c'est cet ours hybride entre
l'ours polaire et le visite mardi à
quelques secondes comme à comment on vit
ça de passer l'été au foie d'amour s'est
très nettement
mais c'est quand même ce sont le soleil
tape comme sa mine de rien ça va quitter
front autour de la gaffe mais en gros
frais rapidement malgré la crème solaire
parce que le soleil tape c'est tellement
beau honnêtement c'est un paysage
on n'imagine pas pour ce 10 e on et au
canada c'est incroyable de voir ça les
gens sont très accueillants veulent
qu'on découvre leur pays on oublie qu'on
ait effectivement l'été puis que la
neige reviendra bientôt à montréal mais
on apprécie d'un merci marie l'art
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin au revoir
au revoir